foreign
Branch Bake Off we'd like to thank you
for being here to help us celebrate the
amazing films that make up our short
list for the 95th Oscars
[Music]
when I watched this sequence I still
find myself smiling as MAV launches over
Ed Harris's character and soars above
the planet I love that I still get
emotional as he becomes the fastest man
alive and I'm still on the edge of my
seat as Matt pushes the dark star to the
Limit as he reaches Mach 10.
one of the things people don't realize
is that all the in-flight dialogue was
recorded in Flight you feel it in the
movie they're experiencing the g-forces
they're having trouble breathing it puts
you in the plane it's amazing I like to
believe that the sound and the mix is a
big reason why we experience this film
in such a visceral and emotional way
he's the best
foreign
[Music]
thing about this one for us was we got
to not only make a cool sounding car but
also treat it almost like a beast
all right
the locations and the incredible sets
they sounded like they should
[Music]
so Matt was Keen to use the acoustic of
that space so we recorded frequency
sweeps in those spaces so that that
acoustic could be captured and applied
to any Foley or ADR I'm here I think
that helped the world
those
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
I think the phrase that kept ringing in
my head is Clarity is King the whole way
of water is about a family it's about an
emotional journey and it's about battles
it's about all of these things that come
at you at a hundred miles an hour with a
lot of sound a lot of dialogue
and a tremendous amount of score that
really weaves an emotional journey of an
avatar and I think the beauty of working
with all of you guys and the whole team
was we were all about Clarity we were
trying to make sure that the story got
told in the most emotional and valuable
way
thank you
this clip it shows the huge spectrum of
contrast that we try to achieve in this
film the contrast is in everything
basically the picture side the
production design and we wanted to
reflect that on the sound side as well
so we go to all the extremes light and
dark loud and quiet
brutality that doesn't hold back
to the delicate moments of Devastation
all the emotions that the soldiers went
through in the story and in the war
[Music]
now would be a good time to to get back
into the car this point in the film in
the 1950s it was very tumultuous time in
the in the 50s and it was a frightening
and dangerous time for The Establishment
[Applause]
and there's one of the Whirlwind of
sound because at this point Elvis
Presley shifted the cultural landscape
of America and and indeed the world
would be changed forever the thing that
stands out to me most was how Austin had
learned to sing like Elvis my technique
was occasionally to monitor playback
Elvis in one ear and Austin's live
singing in the other and it was like a
mirror
misery
[Music]
thank you all for joining us for the
sound bake off thank you to all of the
sound teams congratulations on being
shortlisted and good luck to all of you
[Music]